bonjour jean marc j'espère que vous
allez bien
face à la situation économique le
gouvernement tente de faire redémarrer
l'économie tout en contrôlant la
circulation du virus mais il doit aussi
faire en sorte que le plan de soutien et
de relance répondent à la contrainte
écologique plus de 14 instituts de
recherche dans le monde se sont alliés
pour suivre les plans post co lead alors
pourquoi cette mobilisation générale
maintenant et pourquoi on s'en inquiète
jean marc et bien parce que avec
beaucoup de prudence
on commence à apercevoir le bout du
tunnel avec les vaccins qui vont arriver
alors je dis avec beaucoup de prudence
parce que vous avez un certain nombre de
professionnels qui ont très peur que les
mesures de confinement soit par exemple
durci à faire la fin de l'année alors
qu'ils s'attendent justement à où il
espère un assouplissement
ceci étant on sent bien qu avec le pacs
à la confiance va revenir les projets
les initiatives alors tous les
gouvernements et notamment en europe ont
massivement soutenu les économies ils
vont maintenant sortir des plans de
relance importants qui sont fondées
essentiellement sur l'investissement et
c'est ce dont on parle très précisément
on considère que la relance doit aider
la reprise de l'activité soutenir les
secteurs en difficulté mais surtout
accélérer la mutation qui est engagée la
mutation digital la mutation de
relocalisation industrielle
le made in france le med en europe par
exemple la mutation écologique justement
vers des énergies naturelles des
procédés de fabrication décarbonés
mutations sociales aussi par le
développement des activités de la vie
c'est à dire la santé l'école la
formation bref pour la france tout ça va
représenter plus de 100 milliards
d'euros sur l'année prochaine dont une
partie sera financée par l'europe n'a
d'ailleurs un petit problème parce que
certains pays comme la hongrie et la
pologne ne sont pas d'accord sur le
financement de tous ces investissements
mais est ce que dans ses plans de
relance on va pouvoir concilier ses
objectifs et économique et ses objectifs
écologiques
écoutez c'est tout c'est toute la
question très compliquée qu'il faut
résoudre
regardez ce qui se passe en allemagne
l'allemagne angela merkel c'est une
si l'allemagne qui se vante de faire
beaucoup d'investissements vers elle en
fait effectivement beaucoup il ya des
éoliennes partout mais comme l a pas de
centrales nucléaires et que le vent des
éoliennes ne suffit pas que le soleil
non plus on est dans le nord un bain la
vue rouvrir des centrales à charbon qui
font que l'allemagne est aujourd'hui le
pays qui polluent le plus en europe sans
compter qu aux périodes de pointe mais
l'allemagne est obligée d'acheter de
l'électricité nucléaire à la france est
pas mal un comble alors la question
c'est d'échapper à cette contradiction
entre l'économie d'un côté l'écologie de
l'autre l'objectif de l'économie cette
créer des emplois c'est de sauver des
entreprises c'est de faire de la
richesse faire des profits pour financer
justement les progrès à venir l'objectif
de l'écologie c'est de lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique
ça nécessite des coûts supplémentaires
donc une baisse de la croissance donc
une baisse de la consommation pour
baisser la pollution la voiture
électrique c'est très bien mais il faut
des batteries pour les fabriquer et il
faut de l'électricité faut aussi
fabriqué cette électricité alors
l'allemagne l'espagne la grande bretagne
la france et l'union européenne en
général ont choisi de flécher un tiers
de tous les investissements de relance
vers l'économie verte c'est un choix
historique mais c'est un choix politique
il va être très difficile à dire quand
même pas ce que ça représente un gros 30
milliards et 30 milliards par pays est
ce que c'est tenable
écoutez ça va être compliqué parce qu'il
va falloir je vous le disais aider les
entreprises anciennes qui sont en
difficulté puisque elles sont en risque
de provoquer un chômage massif
beaucoup de mouvements écologistes très
radicaux chez nous et en europe pensent
que l'économie à l'écologie ne sont
compatibles que si on change de modèle
il faut inventer autre chose que le
modèle financier fondé sur la
productivité
fondée sur la concurrence la rentabilité
j'ajoute que ces écologistes ont vu
pendant cette période de crise pendant
cette période de confinement un arrêt de
la croissance est bien l'arrêt de la
croissance a été synonyme de moins de
consommation donc moins de pollution
moins de consommation utile c'était
plutôt pour eux une bonne chose c'était
une expérience sur sauf que la planète
s'est appauvrie on va fabriquer beaucoup
de chômeurs qu'on a fabriqué beaucoup
d'inégalités beaucoup de misère et que
cette mise en veille des populations et
ça c'est un problème il va falloir
régler
merci beaucoup jean-marc pour toutes ces
explications à distance crise sanitaire
oblige merci